foreign
[Music]
foreign
Virgin Islands destined for Miami
address
we did some examinations on the packages
during the x-rays determined some
anomalies that were inside
so it sealed up see if I can open it up
[Music]
inside there's a cake and frosting and
it smells like carrot cake
yep
appears to be cocaine
they have their emblem to identify which
organization it belongs to where it's
going
so we'll do the next one
it has the same narcotics inside
the same envelope so it looks like it
comes from the same drug trafficking
organization
this is unique since I have been here in
Miami I have not seen anything smuggled
in cake they're very inventive when it
comes to it
let me just sway this
and that's four Keys each key proximity
is running about 28 to 30 000.
today an undercover officer will attempt
to deliver these packages their ultimate
goal is to figure out who's going to
receive it and what their involvement is
[Music]
did you make any purchases that you're
bringing back today okay
you didn't buy anything no gifts in your
knees no postcards nothing
where are you guys traveling from Milan
Milan along did you guys make any
purchases of any kind the most important
thing you want to find is narcotics but
this year has been a very big focus on
merchandise
currently we have Milan on the floor
that's a big flight for people who will
purchase a lot of items abroad and don't
declare it
you bring anything back from your trip
any purchases that you made abroad total
value what do you think
perfect have a good night guys
when you spend a lot of money abroad you
pay a higher amount of Duty it's an
import tax
can I see a passport yes
all right just follow me for a minute
all right
foreign
so you spent 14
000. I spent 20. so I'm just declaring
okay do you have all the receipts I put
everything in here for you perfect
460 is a bracelet
1900 that's the leather suitcase
so leather luggage is eight percent
is and what it's made out of because the
purpose of duty is to protect the
economy so if we have a big stake in
something oh okay got it the Tariff rate
is going to be higher because we want
you to buy in the United States
1740 was a sweat
expensive sweater but it's really
brilliant sweater because sometimes you
got to treat yourself right really bad
year and so you know what it was
sometimes good to just enjoy it exactly
because at the end of the day when our
show is over you can't take any of it
with you so you might as well enjoy
while you're here if you're in love with
us and that's what made me think you
know what I'm going to assure myself
exactly
sweater I agree with that I'm just
saying my condolences thank you
so when you add up all of your duty
grand total is 9 15.
thank you
you're saying thank you for declaring
all right
when we see people doing the right thing
it's kind of shocking because we're so
used to people not declaring but we want
to get them out of the inspection area
as fast as possible so we can get back
out to the floor to get the people who
aren't doing the right thing
[Applause]
foreign
let's see what else we have
right now we're at an outside location
at Miami International Airport
let's flip it over we're going to be
inspecting some in transit mail
and Transit mail is mail it's entering
the U.S but it's not intended to stay
here it's going somewhere else
we pick a country and we target that
country
today we picked the Dominican Republic
Dominican Republic most likely we're
looking for cocaine
let's do one bag at a time let's not
rush it I find it great we don't we let
it go
good to go
perfect
this is like an Easter egg hunt
you know
I don't trust this
that's one
let's take a look
there's some type of mechanical part
looks like a actuator pump or something
it looks weird
it has like a thickness inside
let's pass it through again
there's something about it it's kind of
a weird shade to it I'm not sure I
figured I'd take a chance let's look at
it yeah
set it aside
see what else we have
hit it
what is that
yeah let me look at that
it's a drum some type of drum musical
instrument
this one's going to chili
what does it look like
there's definitely something there I
just don't know what it is
[Music]
something wrong there
when you look at the image it looks like
there's something under this Rim right
here it could be glue or it could be
anything but it doesn't look right
we're gonna take it back to the shop
so we got two Parcels we've noticed some
unusual densities so we're going to take
it back to our shop drill it and see if
there's something in there
all right guys thank you for being here
these two boxes right here they were
intercepted by CBP and that's what we're
delivering today
the location it's an apartment building
on the second floor hopefully someone's
there to take the package from us but if
there's no one there they could leave
the box right outside the door and it'll
be clearly visible from the parking lot
we're gonna set up surveillance
monitoring the package If It Moves we'll
follow it wherever it goes and we'll go
from there
inside the cake that's going to be
delivered there's no actual drugs in
there
we went out and we purchased sheet cake
and recreated the cake by hand
it was a little challenging I've never
made a cake in my life but I I fought
through it and uh
we'll see if it works
the goal is the interview the individual
and see what information we can get from
them as far as the supplier usually
there's bigger fish and what we get is
towards the bottom of the totem pole and
we'll work our case up from there
[Music]
so this is our Target location
we're gonna set up right in front of the
apartment to keep an eye on the packages
once delivered
best case scenario is they go into the
box and retrieve the bricks
worst case scenario
the boxes are placed outside with a
Return to Sender
package just arrived at Target location
oh Nelly
the boxes are dropped off at the front
door
it's like fishing you don't have a line
out there
then all of a sudden
[Music]
hi there we go we got a guy coming up
Target is a little over six feet here's
a beard
here we go
all right here we go we got a guy coming
out
mail with a black T-shirt came out of
our Target location
and there he's
texting on his phone right now
one package just went in
one package is inside
let's pick it up the second one second
package is inside
oh he's out
he has both boxes with him
looks like he's locking his door
he's walking down the stairs
he's gonna load the boxes up into his
car and we'll follow him up
there's a phone with him doesn't seem to
be paying much attention to anything
he's headed out so we're gonna see where
he leads us
[Music]
good old Prince
you bring anything back from the trip to
make any purchases collect t-shirts
total value what do you think 50 bucks
all right have a good night get home
safe
hey ma'am see your passport do you have
anything to declare today any purchases
that you might have made abroad any
gifts that you're bringing back
all right just follow me real quick
all right so these are all your bags
right yes everything in the bags belongs
to you and you have nothing to declare
okay you made no purchases
how was your trip good
yeah it's good
[Applause]
no kidding yeah
it's our election now there's nothing
wrong with that
these are all old bags or new bags
does that mean old or new
oh crap
so listen
okay
I asked you if you bought anything did I
not
the answer is yes
okay
I also asked you about the Chanel and
you said it's yours right yeah that's
mine
do you want to elaborate is it new
yes yes
it's new right yeah so how come when I
ask you your response was no I don't
know
it's a big deal we're not talking about
a couple hundred dollars I found a
receipt for four thousand dollars worth
of stock so the two bags I had in my
hands were the two bags that you bought
yes it would have been outside
technically what's supposed to happen is
about a thousand dollars in penalty for
not declaring the stuff
do you understand
do I look like I'm joking a thousand
dollars you spend four thousand dollars
that you did not declare
listen listen listen listen listen stop
talking let me let me stop talking it's
not that has nothing to do with it
listen to me stop talking relax
what's supposed to happen is you're
supposed to pay that fine
but I'm not doing it
if you want to sit here and argue with
me I'll be more than happy for you to
pay the penalty so I'm absolutely not
arguing I'm just like if I'm just okay
but I need you but you should be upset
at yourself for not doing it the right
way I gave you plenty of opportunities
to say that you did buy something you
flat out lied to me and I'm still giving
you an opportunity to amend your
declaration
listen it is what it is
I'm using my discretion because I looked
at the big picture I looked at their
travel history I needed not much travel
so what I'm going to choose to do is
just charge her to duty it's 235.
hopefully she learned her lesson today
but we'll see
if you do this again I can't help you
you understand I'm not telling you you
can't buy stuff but you need to declare
the stuff that you're bringing you
understand all right
you know what side you're free to go all
right sorry about that no worries that
happens
[Music]
let's see what we got on the X-ray today
we're going to inspect both pieces now
that we found suspect on the Airfield
that drum going to Chile
there's radios hard drives electronic
containment TVs you name it we've seen
it loaded
it keeps seeing a little bit of uneven
thickness right here I'm gonna make a
small drill hole see if I can get a
sample of what's in there
let's see what we have
huh
now why is white powder coming out of
that one
I don't know if it's just the material
that I drilled or if it's a narcotic
so I'm gonna test it see what happens
it's a computerized drug test kit has a
built-in library of all the known
narcotics
thousands of files
you can see the laser
no match
this one was a negative
it looks like it's resin
it smells like plastic
so we look for is anomalies anything
that looks strange
sometimes it pans out sometimes it
doesn't but we keep trying
foreign
about to go north on 102 at
yeah he's taking it
for our baby bird
and my number five
I don't know where he was
lost him
[Music]
worst case scenario yeah you could be
dropping off of the boxes at the post
office and just simply say it was
dropped off at his house and it's not
his
so I'm gonna go into the post office and
see if I can figure out what he's trying
to do with those boxes
[Music]
so we are at the post office I was
inside with the subject he's dropping it
off sending the package through priority
mail
all right Target is out of the post
office empty-handed
we are not gonna follow him
the subject's just one of the middle
people that's part of this organization
which is going so far
we'll just hold off until we get as high
as possible and then we'll try to
encounter him again at a later date
yes sir okay so we were able to recover
the package and so I was headed to an
address in Georgia
now that we know the package is going to
Georgia we'll reach out to our
counterparts in Atlanta it's like an
onion a bunch of layers and you just
start peeling and hopefully we can reach
to whoever's up on the top of this
foreign
do you have any foreign currency or just
US dollar
s
how much cash are you traveling with
today a couple hundred bucks all that
good stuff
any currency over ten thousand dollars
is that um one thousand okay
the law is you report currency over ten
thousand dollars how long are you gonna
be here three weeks three weeks all
right nothing over ten thousand dollars
when you fail to declare that money nine
times out of ten is someone's personal
money and they just were afraid but what
we're looking for is any nefarious
purposes your wife she carry money as
well or no yeah I give it to them are
you laundering money or are you
smuggling money is the money drug
related is it related to human
trafficking so our job is to find it in
season
Colombia
okay okay
he's coming from a source country uh for
Narcotics so we would definitely want to
do an inspection on the passenger
is no
foreign
I said okay
see
yeah
no
no
carola is
A Thousand Years
temporary
okay
the fact that this wasn't his first time
bringing large amount of money into the
United States we're gonna talk to him a
little bit more
okay
I want to verify why he had that money
on him and where that money was coming
from
[Music]
the backstory is these two packages were
sent from the U.S Virgin Islands and
they were intercepted in Miami
there was approximately two kilos of
cocaine and cakes on top with a bunch of
frosting it's it's pretty crazy so today
we're doing a controlled delivery
I feel confident that this is probably
going to be the final destination
but we're going to deliver it and see
where we go from there
all right break
our best case for today would be
we make the delivery the packages go
inside the house and we go ahead and
search the residents hopefully find
either proceeds or more narcotics inside
the house we want to figure out how that
drug trafficking operation runs
we got our Target house
there are actually some windows open up
top and we have a vehicle at home
all right a Mercedes is in the driveway
now
Go Time so hopefully everything goes as
planned
all right he's just pulling up now
here to walk to the front
copy
so I can see our undercover actually
walking up the house with one of the
pack bags right now
I gave the first package he said the
names and the guy replied yes
[Music]
both packages were delivered to a young
oh
he's coming out with the boxes
are going to the Mercedes we're
definitely getting movement on the
packages came right out of the house
put them in the car
and is on the move
we'll follow through what would come up
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
you ran the stop sign there but we'll uh
we'll get behind them
pick it up
now I don't know if he's detected
anything or if he's just driving crazy
let's see where he goes but he's driving
like a maniac
okay
thank you
sorry
foreign
so the subject was traveling with about
eight thousand four hundred dollars okay
they are allowed to bring up to ten
thousand dollars without actually
declaring it okay
but in this case we wanted to verify
where that money was coming from
Rita
okay easy
in Florida Florida
okay
great time
okay iPhones 11.
um
foreign
made sense and the fact that his
behavior was consistent and calm and
based on the fact that he did say that
they did file a police report on the
items that were stolen that to me seems
very legitimate so it was uh let go
Dominican Republic for Brussels
when we checked it in the field on the
mobile x-ray machine
it looks like it had some density inside
this tube right here
I have no clue what this is
you know
but we do know a little bit about
mechanics and stuff like that and we
look for things that don't add up to us
and anytime we see a hollow cylinder
that doesn't look good to us because
that's where you're going to hide stuff
I'm gonna run it through this x-ray now
so we're gonna try to find out if that's
something supposed to be there or if
it's not
foreign
[Music]
it's got some weird density you can see
little gaps
this looks like something they would be
going in and out
but when you look at it
the rod doesn't go all the way through
it's like a fake tip
that comes the fun part we got to figure
out how to take it apart
oh
my God
this is solid but this is not right okay
we can cut the cap off
there we go
foreign
[Music]
there we go
right there I think we got Coke bro
that's not supposed to be inside a metal
cylinder
make a sample
cocaine hydrochloride
we're like little kids we're happy
we play a game of hide and seek all day
long it's fun when we find something
so we're gonna try now to take the
narcotics out we'll try to get an
accurate weight
the reason we were having a hard time
with the X-ray is they were smart
it's an aluminum tube
we should be able to see an aluminum
tube pretty good
well they were smart the line they were
lit
what protects you from x-rays pure lead
so they decided to basically line the
aluminum with this lead piece to try to
like make it seem like if it's just a a
regular piece of aluminum to prevent us
from looking inside but my friend over
here is smarter than the average bear
he's been doing this for a while so yeah
we went fishing we got a fish today
they're good at what they do
today we were better
[Music]
the price of cocaine getting it to
Europe it's about triple the price of
what it is in Miami so that just makes
the seizure so much more relevant just
because we know we made a dent today
into their profits but the important
thing is it's not getting on the streets
so it's all that matters
thank you
[Music]
how much maybe eight out of five eight
thousand five hundred eight thousand
five hundred
so we're about to be here
how you doing
any currency over ten thousand dollars
you step down here for me
all right so I'm going to take a look at
you carry them any checks Travelers
checks
I stopped the passenger off the South
Korea flight from Seoul which is the
source flight for Undeclared currency I
asked how much he was traveling with and
he declared 350 dollars all right I'm
just going to take a quick look at some
of your bags all right
[Music]
what are these
are they a traveler's check this one
yeah what is it cashless cashier's check
the eight cashier's checks total 160
million Korean Won which when you
convert it to US Dollars it's a hundred
and thirty six thousand eighty two
dollars
so that's a big discrepancy from the 350
dollars declared to me initially
when it comes to Undeclared currency
you're talking about money laundering
and possibly tax evasion
okay I I make mistake okay I I keep uh
that morning you know so I forgot okay
so you didn't tell me about them because
you forgot about them it wasn't that you
didn't yeah all the time I put here so I
don't know
it's hard to believe that an amount of
money at that level you don't know
what's in your pocket
what are you gonna do
going to do so you're gonna take this
directly to the bank and put it in the
bank deposit yeah when you get here
you're gonna do it here no no no I'm not
using
why are you see
the Lego this one is my money right yeah
my money so how long have you had this
yeah
[Music]
so you just have 150 000 in your wallet
at all times
well you fail to declared over 100 000
there's something up about it
all right let's go take this with you
we're gonna go into the room
have a seat for a minute
I don't know if he's detected anything
or if he's just talking crazy
yeah
so he did a maneuver which we call a
heat check he pulled into this apartment
complex and then abruptly started flying
down the road which is a maneuver trying
to detect law enforcement
y'all can roll up this way yeah
rather him get spooked and maybe kill
somebody on the road
I have a feeling he's going to bail out
and run you feel comfortable to pull it
now
the boxes are out of the car right now
and it looks like he's taking them
towards another house turn on new lights
so we didn't even plan for this
all right
plan for this
God
he had the box and he's out of the car I
think he was gonna drop him into gazebo
down there saw me go back in the car to
haul ass and then um okay Rory stopped
him right here
he's in custody right now our guys all
did a great job in stopping him from
getting out on the main roads
we're just doing an inventory of the car
the cake is sitting here so obviously he
got into it and saw what was in here
[Music]
he did have a loaded gun it's a Glock 17
nine millimeter that was another threat
to us so it's good that we went ahead
and took him down when we did
it's still a work in motion now we're
going to go back and search the
residents
foreign
was negative
who did you say is coming
Kim the female officer oh okay okay so
she speaks and reads credential should
get a better read on everything okay all
right
[Music]
we have an officer who is of Korean
descent and she's currently interviewing
the subject to understand why he didn't
declare the money purpose of the money
and whether he's telling the truth or
not
everyone actually has been doing
business for 30 years
taxes he wasn't even aware that was in
there because he had it for so long and
I started changing the scholarities and
this is just a misunderstanding
you said that you forgot it was in there
I don't know how true that is but being
that you failed to declare the money
when you came into the country you
violated the law
it's over a hundred thousand dollars is
a lot for us to overlook so we're gonna
seize the money today but you'll have
the opportunity to get the money back at
a later date
you have to prove where the money comes
from what account the money is in and
there was no nefarious purposes you can
get all of it back or you may not get
any of it back it depends on how you
Pledge Your Case
okay you understand
okay
so saying that a total of one hundred
and thirty six thousand eighty two
dollars in Cashiers checks was found
today the small amount that you would
declare to me that all stays with you
it's just the checks were taken okay
this currency seizure is one of if not
the biggest currency seizures inbound
that we've had this year
there was no info that we had prior
about this individual it was a complete
cold stop so it was a great great job by
the team as a whole and it makes us more
motivated to go out the next day to keep
working hard
okay just make sure next time you
declare your money okay
all right
we found some electronics and some
paperwork and then found a large
quantity of U.S currency I think there
were four of them that were labeled 5K
for five thousand dollars
this was very successful I had a lot of
working parts but her team worked well
together with all the evidence we
gathered here we're going to be in
contact with Miami HSI to see what
connection there is between this guy and
the guy that actually picked up the
package in Miami
oh it may seem small that we just took
down one target it's really huge in a
large scope of dealing with drug
trafficking organizations
[Music]
[Music]
thank you